[Music]
here in this video we will take a look
at the most powerful monsters that
doctor strange has fought and defeated
there are nine of them which we have
included all of them have a monstrous
form that aren't human sized or
human-like of course there are other
powerful villains like doctor doom baron
model and casilius but in this list we
will only focus on the powerful demons
monsters and god-like entities that have
faced doctor strange in a way and lost
to him so let's get to it
starting with number 9 the undying ones
these are creatures who serve the being
called the nameless one and they are
demons from another dimension their
biggest advantage is their overwhelming
numbers however they are also very
dangerous in a one-on-one battle because
of their immense strength size and
resistance to most forms of conventional
attack the majority of these
lovecraftian creatures have mystical
abilities and can shapeshift as well the
undying ones invaded planet earth and
this forced doctor strange to form a
group called the defenders along with
namor from atlantis and the hulk and
they promptly defeated them and sent
them back to where they came from
and number eight we have despair he was
created 20 000 years ago by the dweller
in darkness out of terror by the sinking
of atlantis and lemuria he was given
some of the dweller's consciousness
and later gained his own self
autonomy or independence despair uses
illusions and hallucinations to instill
terror and despair in his victims he has
the ability to read the minds and
emotions in order to bring forth the
people's innermost fears he is a member
of the fear lords and in one instance he
made the dweller and a nightmare compete
in creating the great fear but this ends
up in terrorizing humans up to a point
where people's fear turned into despair
and then he became all the more powerful
from that and even though he became
stronger he was still defeated by doctor
strange in the end
at number 7 we have nightmare nightmare
is a class 3 demon the ruler of the
dream dimension and he is one who
influences the dreams of living beings
as they sleep feeding on humanity's
psychic energies in particular he uses
the energy he extracts from their
subconscious minds to keep himself alive
he actually requires it in order to
survive and without it he would perish
nightmare is extremely powerful in his
dimension and maybe even virtually
omnipotent within it but outside of it
he is less so doctor strange has been
able to cast spells and illusions to
defeat him in the waking world he is
another one of the fear lords along with
the dweller in darkness despair and
others
number six satanish
one of the many faces of evil satanish
is a class ii demon or hell lord who
rules his own hellish spirit realm
populated by damned souls enslaved
through bargains they struck with him
while alive satanish and the other hell
lords originated as fragments of a mass
of dark mystical energy remaining from
the battle between the demogorge and the
evil elder gods in his first appearance
in doctor strange issue number 174
satanish is revealed to be the hidden
master of lord necron
a powerful magician who bargained his
soul for more abilities
strange defeats necron and in turn
defeats the will and scheming plans of
satanish
at number 5 we have cathorn this monster
was an elder god and was the first
practitioner of black magic on earth
when all the other elder gods
degenerated into demons the demogorge
was unleashed to devour them gathorn
fearing it created a dark hole a book
filled with dark magic spells and then
disappeared into another pocket
dimension to escape the god either
catholic has always been more associated
with wanda maximov and her use of chaos
magic but on occasion has come into
contact with doctor strange their
battles have always involved strange
attempting to prevent catholics
re-emergence by breaking his possession
over models in doctor strange sorcerer
supreme issue 90 he saves victoria
monteci from giving birth to catharine
in secret empire issue 7 he breaks the
demon's hole over wanda maximoff
at number 4 we have the dweller in
darkness a member of the demonic cabal
known as the fear lords this
extra-dimensional behemoth has murky
origins and terrifying powers possibly
surviving from a previous universe the
dweller originates from the evarian
dimension the dweller appears in person
in doctor strange volume 2 issue 30
hoping to feed on strange and stranger's
love interest clear on their fear and
escape from the ancient spell binding
him in a mysterious dimension and
although he did manage to do that his
minions the shade trolls and later the
dreamweaver were all defeated by strange
so in a way strange did manage to fight
off the dweller's schemes but in the end
strange then succumbed to fear and a
dweller declared himself victorious so
this one is kind of like a one win and
one lose for strange here
at number three we have mephisto
he is a class 2 demon or hell lord
mephisto rules a fiery nether realm that
he refers to as hell or hades though
this is neither the biblical hell nor
pluto's olympian hades
or is it hades hades whatever mephisto
is one of the most powerful entities in
the marvel universe the comic book
equivalent of the devil and he's also
nearly godlike in his own dimension able
to even withstand an attack from
galactus the world devourer mephisto can
also reality shape-shift and cast
illusions on a scale that is near
impossible to comprehend
in doctor strange damnation
issue 1 mephisto and dr strange played a
game of blackjack for the souls of the
people of las vegas and fortunately
won the game
in another instance in the sinister war
storyline in amazing spider-man vol 5
the 204s strange and mephisto play
another fateful game of chance
one that ends with the freeing of harry
osborne's soul at number two we have
dormammu
we have come to bargain
dormammu is a primordial
interdimensional entity who wields
apocalyptic levels of supernatural power
and is the ruler of the dark dimension
described by marvel as one of the
greatest forces of evil in the universe
dormammu is one of the few villains who
can lay claim to being doctor strange's
arch enemy or maybe even more than that
as the creator and manipulator of
satanish he arguably dwelves the hell
lords in terms of sheer strength he also
held his own against agamotto who in dr
strange sorcerer supreme issue 43 holds
his own against galactus himself in the
mcu in doctor strange the movie strange
who is immensely overpowered by domamu
still manages to defeat him by using the
time stone to drop de marmo in a
never-ending loop forcing the monster to
leave the planet and does in a way being
defeated by strange
and number one schuma
this monster is the archetypal class 3
demon native to an extra dimensional
realm and a ruler of a hundred
dimensions
he is one of the old ones who came to
earth untold millions of years ago
ruling it and feasting on mankind's
ancestors in mighty avengers vol 2 issue
2 doctor strange is forced by ebony
moore to summon a tiny fragment of the
being known as shumagarath into
manhattan while being all powerful in
his own dimension
this small avatar of him was defeated by
strange however his entire being would
have been too powerful for anything to
stop him even jomamu and mephisto
acknowledged it as being more powerful
than them
anyway with that we come to the end of
this list so do hit that like button for
support subscribe as well to be a part
of the minecube family comment your own
list
but most of all smash the bell icon for
regular updates on new videos right here
on this channel till the next one take
care fam